here is Stacy Abrams and Stacy Abrams
who of course has no resume this is a
woman who the only thing she is known
for besides for setting a record at the
Golden Corral buffet correct is uh she
ran for governor last time and then when
she lost she said that it was an
illegitimate election but I didn't lose
I got the votes but we won't know
exactly how many because of how they
cheated yeah okay this is about six
seven months ago she had no problem
sitting there with her [ __ ] eating grin
that's just too close for comfort while
a bunch of kids who were at no risk of
covet who will likely have speech
defects and delayed speech and all sorts
of social conditioning problems anyway
she's running again yesterday okay we
saw a record turnout for early voting it
does not mean that voter suppression
doesn't exist we're better than it and
we are going to bring it and we're going
to win this election record people are
voting but she just wants you to know if
I don't get what I want at the end
obviously some Shenanigans collusion
you're not working